what's going on reject nation Greg
al-baqir with urban economy I would be
crazy from YouTube and Twitter she live
streams plays games also game tavern on
YouTube where her and Dan Seibert get
together with a couple of buddies and
they play games as well links in
description box yeah III is upon us one
of the biggest risk to come out of III
is Assassin's Creed origins the
announcement trailer now I've been given
a disclaimer every video that I'm sure
has annoyed you guys by now because I
keep mentioning it how my gamer friends
set up throughout the week so that way
you know each one gets the trailers that
most perfectly suit them and I keep
saying like I'm not much of a gamer I'm
gonna flip that I'm a huge human it play
all I played every Assassin's for every
one of them not just totally play they
don't have to be great I lent you yeah
he's the ones you let me three years ago
I have totally played through every
moment I was 100% oh my I can tell you
everything there is to know about every
Assassin's Creed ian is maybe worth your
time for me to be here she never even
touched it so I don't know what you're
doing here I get why I'm here over the
first videos I did on your channel as an
assassin's creed yes yeah hopefully 42
Stan hmm some you guys met yeah I'm
sorry if you don't know me or remember
at all I'm a huge Assassin's Creed fan
too cute I'm the biggest Assassin's
Creed a huge really
Emily's going to be impressed by the
visual of our the first origin the
monetarists to see the gods refer to
tame their beasts
[Music]
the first to guard the soul from evil
Lilith Helen and conquered this land and
built an empire
[Music]
it's worth what there are whispers of
The Wizard of rubber hood all in the
shadows
Wow they are the first to call
themselves the Assessors later message
I'm in the alley here
[Music]
no available October 27th pre-order now
and get a bonus mission secrets of the
first pyramids we order it are you gonna
free already
I need snakes freak me out man you're
late
oh yeah that's one of my biggest fears
that and going number two in someone
else's house of course it is today
imagine it's snake in the person's
toilet while going number two in some
bad field you know I had a snake right
yeah I know
shame fun fact and colleague my minor is
actually archeology was focused on
Egyptology really fun bag I once got an
A in history class and that's only cuz I
paid attention one semester in the
Egyptian time when I learned about
Osiris and Anubis and because that's a
ting the reason why I really loved the
mummy Booya the night you go ahead so
that made me go I'm actually really
interested in this oh yeah now the
Egyptian time period is an especially
appealing time period to me seeing the
architectural designs of the fact that
you can do like Assassin's Creed type of
parkour gameplay in like going down
pyramids and [ __ ] that's really cool I'm
really interested to see how they're
going to incorporate historical figures
because that's something that man Chai's
tends to do as a whole is during
gameplay they bring in real people from
the respective period that the game is
set in so I'm curious to see how they're
going to play around I'm pretty sure you
play as Moses I think the villain is
ramsay and this is about you leak
obviously graphics look cool supposed to
build and you could say any game trailer
graphics do look at me know is you know
every year things do get better and
things do look better and play
and every year but all I saw last year
but it's general because it's kind of
said to be that way
Assassin's Creed is see I get
overwhelmed the thought of starting
Assassin's Creed because there's so many
of them
I'm going to have to really commit some
time here but whenever I see a trailer
for Assassin's Creed game I'm like I
don't want to play so where plays a big
thing of mine I recently started archery
this year I love doing archery and
whenever he's doing like you know
shooting like five arrows at once
totally realistic I want to do that
because I I can do that I can shoot five
arrows at once it hit all my targets
because I'm that impressive man and I'm
Tommy what you always riding the horse
season with the word called not genetics
right now it's at archery yeah someday
something else yeah no they're not
around horse first anyway
personal notes but all this I pronounced
I'm alright origins so this is the story
of the first Assassin's Creed the first
mother first brother yeah yes okay
really cool tell me your thoughts and
feelings on these things that make sense
that it was starting the Egyptian time
because that's when everything began so
I'm really excited because we haven't
really gotten much of an origin story at
all so this is for me going to be
fantastic to set the fan of the
franchise because we've played through
so many different characters nuts that's
something where you know you're like you
have to invest so much time but none of
the games except like one two and three
yes you plays a chunk but the rest of
them you can really kind of play on
their own because they are different
people different characters different
points in history so it's not that you
need to start with the very first one
and I'll go until recent like Assassin's
Creed one two and three they're all made
around at them yes and the rest of them
are just kind of their own thing so you
can literally take any of the more
recent ones and played our own storage
and is this origin tale supposed to be
to Assassin's Creed one or just all the
whole Assassin's Creed world in general
I mean from what it's implying it's the
start of the entirety of the world you
brother on everything okay I just I'm so
excited to see how they're gonna play
with this oh I'm excited to learn how to
outswim an alligator such as underwater
and kill it ya know as a lot of these
like crazy mystical elements like it
seems like they're really taking
advantage of the time period I'm not
super familiar with how Assassin's Creed
works I know one of the cool things is
the historical fictional elements to it
really really honor history
yeah here it seems to be dealing with
some Egyptian mystical elements in
mythology is Assassin's Creed known for
that where there's stuff in here where
you're like is that historically
accurate you know giant [ __ ] you oh
there are giant snakes in the world
about that is an accurate stupid
statement Amano like you look a little
this one deal with like curses and I
mean I could from what we've gotten it
there is definitely like a mystical
element however not really heavily
played off of it more of modern-day
technology versus technology then it's
like a science fiction element infused
into historical fiction yeah as opposed
to like magic and curses in all things
yeah yeah because I'm one of the rare
take place in the Egyptian time period
where stuff like that is usually omitted
on at least in cinema I'd imagine that
they they would try to include some of
that here because it kind of looks like
that the thing that we have to remember
from this time period in Egypt is that
no like technology as we know it was not
a thing I have I come
oh yeah okay I'll be back amendments do
statue water or laser pressure thing ass
that's how they do the hieroglyphs
yes employees very definitely should I
mean in my opinion they should play more
on symmetrical elements for this
particular one because that technology
is lacking okay I get what you're saying
I get reader saying oh and the gladiator
battle I got what I do with the battle
is really cool I mean this is a time
period that it's just so pride
that I miss this specific time period
there in Bogota fastest rate on familiar
with you know they have like guns and
stuff this is like barbaric status you
know it's like Spears arrows swords and
that's all you're really dealing with
your animals that are very dangerous
yeah
how about the giant snake I don't know
if I can handle that I mean II had
Batman Chamber of Secrets yeah it kind
of does remind me of that I looked at
what it looks good it does look like a
really cool game maybe the interesting
thing about SAS inscri games to mean is
that whatever they announce it they come
out rather soon I feel like every other
game wait three more years okay so do
you personally feel the quality of the
games go down though no no I get better
okay I guess for a game for a franchise
that keeps releasing games so often I
can't keep imagine the quality might go
down a little bit like graphics would
improve but I'm just wondering does the
core does the gameplay and all that get
better or does it just kind of stay the
same it's I mean if you're doing an
origins tale you got to put your all
into this one I mean I like the idea of
the world of it I'm familiar with the
world because I've played some of the
chicken with you but yeah it's like the
Brotherhood and all that's always been
established as the thing so to see like
okay here's the specific origin tale
from where they start you really got to
enhance like storytelling here right
yeah and I feel like it does get better
and they do it the way they do it
because of how they've set it up because
no aside from one two or not three
because three was separate I had legs
all mixed up but for the modern the more
recent ones they are all based of
different people in different time
series I feel like that's how they're
able to do what they do is because they
are basically well yeah and they can't
focus on one person's story how they are
going about doing everything they do and
they don't have to keep to a strict
storyline of one character across
multiple games anymore that contributes
usually to the series because they're
able to play around a lot more with new
characters new people new time created
everything that was that cool well what
gets me excited is
coming off of the high of that amazing
Assassin's Creed movie that's what's
getting me invested in this does that
movie was perfect
it definitely resembles the game
represents it it's true authentic form I
should never fans of the game the movie
did pure justice quote me on that
Chloe don't be sad there's a reason it
got like a hundred seventeen percent on
Rotten Tomatoes yeah this is a
box-office smash global phenomenon and
now I'm officially excited for the next
installment in the video game franchise
this is going to redeem everything no
one cares about that movie hey you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell ELISA be crazy YouTube
and twitch she live streams Wales games
that's what she does I go on once a year
and it is so much fun then six hours we
have to finish the last edition we
didn't finish this yeah yeah we're going
to be thirty girl file I played for
three and a half hours never picked it
back up again at games tavern heard and
the clay games with friends is my friend
and it's a good time you to come
enjoyment ELISA
thanks for being here thank you for
bringing me back I missed it here thank
you it new question well I mean here on
the show the channel the show first came
on when you're out like what like
thirteen hundred subscribers yeah
sixteen hundred maybe it was under two
thousand yeah small yeah so it's like
it's seeing the ride the relative a
channel yeah we're was like were
announces its no it's like a studying
planning this may be nice
hey guys hey guys make it make it keep
going up calls an emotional roller
coaster